Hey ! Hey salut !
Hey...salut !
Et c'est qui elle ?
(rires) de quoi ? De quoi ?
Euh... Comment tu vas depuis la dernière fois ?
Bah ça va...
Salut !
Tu... Tu me présentes pas ?
Euh... si si bien-sûr, Adrien je te présente euh...
(sonnerie)
Oh putain...! Allez go go go on s'active !
Il nous faut un nom !
C'est pas Estelle l’infirmière?
Non!
C'est pas la meuf de Ludo?
Pff! Pas du tout!
C'est elle non?
Euh..........
Peut-être qu'elle s'est fait une teinture...
Sinon..J'avais..Euh...
Nan mais venez eh, on s'en branle on dit un prénom au pif. On dit euh.... Sandrine!
Putain on a besoin de plus de temps, faites le parler vous!
Euh.........
J'ai besoin de 4 millisecondes, tout au plus
4 millisecondes, putain mais c'est beaucoup trop long 4 millisecondes, Allez!
J'ai la première lettre, c'est un S!
Ah! Le S de Sandrine!
Attendez on est sûr de ça? Parce que des fois on croit que ça commence par un S et puis...
Nan, c'est sûr, y'a un S dedans!
Ssss............
J'ai un souvenir!
Ok, on est entré.
Il est là!
Oh merde, on était bourré...
Mathias?
C'est qui ça?
Elle était avec nous à la soirée, c'est qui?
Elle est bonne.
Putain, il nous faut un nom! Réfléchis, merde!
Réfléchis!
Josi...Josianne
Non, Josianne c'est le nom de notre concierge, allez!
Euh........
...Lucie.
Lucie! C'est Lucie!
Lucie!
(cris de joie)
Non, Lucie c'est ma soeur! Moi c'est Sandrine.
Tu vois? Je vous l'avais dit, Sandrine!
Je l'avais dit tout à l'heure!
*musique d'action*
71 04 c'est ça?
-Oui, c'est ça.
Je te bippe pour que t'aies le mien?
-Ouais.
Ah..Ah bah je l'avais déjà en fait.
(bruit de sonnerie)
Mathias. Je m'appelle Mathias.